- Say hi to all the puppies.
- Oh, puppies.
- You wanna play?
Hi, hey.
- Oh my gosh, I know
you want 'em all, right?
- I do.
- I can't do it.
Okay, so are you a big sports ball fan?
- Oh, huge.
- You are?
- Well, as are you, right?
'Cause you love sports ball.
- So love it.
- Sports ball.
- Okay, let's sit down, but wait,
can we really pause and pick up the crap?
It's a real thing.
- No, no.
- Wait, you're right, it
is right by your chair.
- I just meant, no I don't care.
I will smell dog (beep) this entire show.
(cheers)
Okay so, you love sports ball like me,
but does Jack watch, your
little boy, does he watch?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, we
both don't understand it.
He might understand it, he's seven.
I think he understands it a
little bit better than I do.
- Better than my kids,
yeah mine are (mumbles)
- I mean, there's these things,
they're yards, I don't know.
They seem like
- There's a yellow line that disappears.
- Yeah, there's like flags
that go down or whatever.
But, having said that
- Look at the little one holding it down!
- Hey, Kelly!
I am your guest.
- I'm so sorry.
(laughs)
I'm so sorry I got distracted.
- No, it's fine.
I just thought you'd be
interested in what I had to say
about your sports ball.
- This dog is climbing.
You're climbing up.
- He's not on my team.
- Are you wanting up?
Are you wanting up here?
No, so y'all, see, he
doesn't really understand it
but he's entertained by it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I'm back, I'm back.
(laughs)
So wait, so is there
- No, it is.
It's just, it's puppy distraction.
- It is, and look, he's climbing you.
- Oh, you wanna be a
part of my team, I know.
- Okay, you're not though.
She's fluff.
Is there anything you've felt,
this is a real question,
'cause I 'member I was talking
on your podcast, I love Unqualified,
and I 'member, yeah, I loved it.
And, is there anything you felt like
you were ill-prepared for, with kids?
'Cause there was so many for me.
- I mean, to be honest, kinda nothing.
- Nothing?
- No, no, no that was a terrible delivery.
Everything.
And especially in Los Angeles.
There's a whole school,
I went to public school.
- I did too.
- Yeah, and
- Boy, but if you were
tryin' to get your kids
not in public school it's like a
- And they tell you, even
when you're pregnant here,
like, there'll be people
that creep into your lives
that are like, oh, well you
gotta like get enrolled now.
And you're like, for what?
- It's in my womb.
- Yeah, and like what's wrong with,
and then it's like, well
but if you don't get him
in the school, then they
won't get in to the coll--
- And then he's just
gonna fail in life, yeah.
- Right, and it's like, he's
already going to fail in life.
(laughs)
- But you need something
to talk about in therapy.
- I don't need to spend a ton of money
to ensure this reality.
I love you Jack, wherever you are.
I love you.
I'm sure he's watching.
- Wherever you are,
someone's watching my child.
They're fine.
(laughs)
- Oh, whatever's happening
inside this mitt feels soft
and warm, and kinda sexy.
(audience laughs)
Man, I need a boyfriend.
- That is the word on the street.
(audience laughs)
- Maybe this bra's gonna
change my whole dating life.
- Wearing it for a couple
of days, gotten any feelers?
- Just me for right now.
- All right, y'all, I'm
hangin' out with Anna Faris,
Ref Dan, and a whole bunch of cute puppies
in honor of this weekend's big game.
That was Anna in the show Mom,
which you can see Thursdays on CBS.
So Anna, the show is
in it's seventh season,
that's awesome!
- Yes.
- Like that's amazing!
- Yeah, yeah!
- That's a lot of seasons.
- You're comin' in to like
Friends territory, because like
- Well, I mean, I feel like
I could buy a small boat.
(laughs)
Not like a "Friends"
boat, but a small one.
- But a row boat, a really good one.
- Yeah, like, I don't know,
a 19-footer, or something.
Will you come on my boat?
- I would come on your boat.
Let's do your podcast on your boat.
- I don't know how to pilot it, but
- I can actually drive a boat.
- Okay, all right.
- I had a pontoon boat.
- We gotta call a foul, I'm sorry.
- Oh.
- Uh-oh.
- A foul, a foul on the play.
- Intentional growling.
- [Kelly] Okay, you know
what, watch it over there.
- [Ref] Sorry, has to happen.
- Yeah, thank you Dan
for keeping them in line.
- No problem.
- [Kelly] Yeah, y'all
pay attention over there.
- It's on Dante, your fave too.
- I actually really love Dante,
and I'm very nervous.
My husband is so nervous backstage.
We do not need another dog.
Dante's got an ego.
- And the ego is too big.
- Look at him, I love
him though, he's fierce.
He just wants it.
Okay, so I love that with Mom
though, you actually tackle,
it's a comedy, but you tackle
some pretty dark issues.
- Yeah, we do.
- That's good, I think!
- As I laugh, no it's, it's, it's
(laughs)
death, addiction, (mumbles).
But no, I love doing the show.
I love that we get to take on,
it's a funny show,
and that we get to be dramatic and real,
and it seems to be really touching people,
which is awesome.
- Yeah, 'cause it is real-life situations,
and you have to laugh at some point.
Anybody struggling with anything,
at some point you have to laugh,
and then build a bridge.
- Well you just have
to laugh at a funeral,
that's what I always say.
- Oh my gosh.
- That was so morbid.
- This is actually real.
I either go like (wails),
I don't even have to know the person.
Like I am just so sad, like at a funeral,
or I get church giggles.
I get the giggles and I can't stop,
and I'm like, (laughs).
And I just like I get so uncomfortable.
- Like what does this all mean?
I guess we're all headed there and
- Everything starts getting very dark.
- This is I'm sure what
you guys all wanna hear.
- It's what they're all
thinking, they're fine.
So I was on your podcast and, well hello.
- I know, and thank you for doing that.
- Come here, I loved it though,
but tell everybody what it's about.
Why is it called Unqualified?
- So, I do this podcast
called Unqualified,
and it's a relationship podcast,
and we give people relationship
advice, attempt to,
'cause I'm really bad at it.
'Cause I don't know what I'm doing.
- [Kelly] That's funny.
- And I wish I could swear.
Because I would emphasize that more,
but maybe the dogs will.
- Is there anyone though
that you feel like on your,
'cause people always ask
me, now that I have a show,
is there anyone I'm dying to have on?
Is there anyone you're dying
to have on your podcast?
- Lil' Kim.
- Lil' Kim?
I love you right now.
(laughs)
That's awesome.
Most people would be like...
- Yeah, you guys can feel it.
- That's awesome, why Lil' Kim?
I love this.
- Well, okay,
the first red carpet I walked,
it was for the MTV Movie Awards,
and Lil' Kim was right behind me.
And she was just wearing, what
do they call those things?
- [Audience Member] Pasties.
- Pasties, yeah, pasties.
Somebody knew that right away.
- She's got some on right now, it's odd.
That's how we roll.
- [Anna] Yeah, yeah, yes!
- You know what, I'm not gonna lie
if I worked that hard for that body
I might show it off like that.
Oh, you can't eat the flowers.
Look at Dante.
Of course I picked the psycho, I love it.
- Dante.
- Get it, Dante!
Dante, you got another flag
on the play coming bro.
You're gonna vomit.
You shouldn't eat that.
So you'd love to have her on your show.
- Yes, yeah.
- [Kelly] She'd be interesting.
She'd be a cool guest, I agree.
- If we get her,
because it'll be with
your help, will you--
- We are sending out a pigeon right now.
(audience laughs)
Lil' Kim, you need to go Unqualified.
I did, it's amazing, I'll do it with you.
We'll all get on, there you go.
- Yeah, pasties or no.
We'll accept you any which way.
- Pasties, anything you
wanna wear, it's fine.
Everyone is welcome, it's all,
that was Dante too.
Dante, you need to calm down, man.
You need to calm down
like Taylor Swift said.
Okay, I hear though you
gave my producers a request.
- I did wanna host your
show for just a minute.
- Well we gotta switch seats.
- All right, are you sure?
- You gotta be in the host seat.
(audience cheers)
Okay, here we go.
Oh, you're, is this one lower?
I feel like it's lower, anyway.
- Okay, Kelly, thank you
so much for being here.
- You know, it's a busy schedule,
but I fit it in, 'cause I love you.
- No, thank you so much, truly.
- You're welcome, it's fine.
- I'm a huge fan, and it's
an honor that you're here.
- Ditto.
- So I have to ask you,
I am exhausted doing one
podcast interview, you know,
a week, so you do this show everyday.
Well, my show, everyday, and The Voice.
What is your secret?
- I was just asked this,
and I feel like it was around my mom,
'cause my mom ended up saying,
you've always been like this.
Like in high school, I had like four jobs,
and I was always doing stuff.
Like at school, like student council,
or in, you know a musical or something.
And Dante's crazy.
Definitely, definitely wants
a rambunctious home, that one.
- What was you favorite musical?
- I did many, but I'd say
my favorite was probably
Seven Brides for Seven Brothers.
I loved playing Milly.
You know what it was?
This is actually interesting,
I've never told anybody this.
Good job interviewing.
I was doing Seven Brides
for Seven Brothers,
it was one night and it
was double-cast that year
and that had never happened in our time,
and so the other cast got all the shows.
We got like one.
(hisses)
I know, anyway.
But we worked so hard,
but we got to that one song, One Man,
and it was actually the first time,
'cause I grew up singing opera,
it was the first time I
found like my chest voice,
my gut voice, like and
really started belting out.
And it was like such a freeing moment.
- Wait, what's the difference though?
- It was like basically,
oh you know Sister Act?
You know when she does the thing
with the stomach, Oh Happy Day?
- So it's like the diaphragm difference.
- Yeah, and it was just using all,
yeah, and it was just kinda
switching gears for me
from doing opera, and you
have to be so perfect.
And you have to be,
it became less about
perfection and technique
and more about passion.
And it was a really, really
awesome moment for me.
I felt like I was flying on stage.
I've never told that story
in my whole life, wow.
I've never told that story.
Well done.
- [Anna] I love that.
- Are you looking for a co-host position?
- Yes I am.
And I still want to hear you sing it,
but we can do that later.
- I know, I can't remember it.
I'm 37.
- Well, we'll work on this.
- Yes, let's do it, let's do it.
I just love that I look
like Dr. Evil holding
like a, you know.
- But he's on my team,
I just want you to know.